hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
one of the distinctive terms that you're
going to see in cynic philosophy more
broadly but also especially in the cynic
Epistles these letters that are probably
wrongly attributed to some of the key
thinkers like diogenes and karates is
this term toil and it's used both as a
noun ponos and it's used as a verb ponen
to engage in toil and the idea is that
these are things that you know we don't
necessarily want to do it's work it's
something we have to struggle in order
to do and this is so important to cynic
philosophy that in letter 16 he tells us
cynic philosophy is that of diogenes the
cynic is one who toils according to this
philosophy whole
the one who is toiling right and so this
is not something you could say
incidental or accidental it's right
there at the very heart of the cynic way
of life and in letter four he sets out a
really interesting and short uh
encapsulation you could say of this so
it runs whether toil is something to be
chosen or avoided continue to toil away
in order that you might not toil for by
not toiling toil is not avoided on the
contrary it is even pursued now there's
a lot of toil going on in there and you
might be doing some work to try to
figure out precisely what is going on in
this letter addressed to uh
let's break it down a bit I think that
might be help so to begin with put aside
all the toiling and then think about
choosing or avoiding and pursuing right
Hydro tone is is to choose Falcon to
avoid or to try to go away from right
is to pursue to chase after and so what
is he saying here well these are the
basic terms you could say for
deliberation and ethics and moral
philosophy Prudential action in general
in the ancient world in basically every
single type of philosophy there's this
understanding that some things are to be
chosen some things to be avoided or
rejected some things because they're
chosen are to be pursued this is basic
practical reasoning that he's talking
about here and when we're doing
practical reasoning quite typically
we're thinking in terms of like
trade-offs or what we're going to
prioritize what we're going to give
space to what we're going to deny space
to how we're going to try to arrange our
life so the question then is well what
did we make of toil as a general
category of activity and we could say
that part of what we need to read into
this is that there's some toil that we
can willingly take on on and you know
exercise ourselves through and we could
call that good toil right and then
there's toil that we're going to have to
deal with if we don't do the good kind
of toil stuff it's not what we want
right but it's got to be we could
translate it as hassles or a whole lot
of extra work or pick whatever else you
want so you know I think everyone is
familiar with this notion of do a job
right at the beginning and then you'll
have less work to do later uh you know
it could be that you're just lazy or
slip shot or you you tried to conceal
the fact that you didn't do what you're
supposed to do if you get caught now you
got to fix it right and this applies to
everything in in life you could say
there's let's take relationships just as
a side note
relationships are work right they're not
this beautiful idyllic everything is
going great all the time if you want to
be in a friendship if you want to be
married to somebody if you want to have
a good familial relationship even if you
want to just be a good co-worker or a
neighbor you got to put in the work and
if you don't do it if you Slough off or
if you cut Corners later on you're going
to have more work to do and it's not
going to be work that you're happy
engaging in and being forced to do so
whether toil is something to be chosen
or avoided the cynic thinks that you
should choose some toil right so
continue to toil away keep on doing the
kind of toil that is required why so
that in order that you might not toil so
that you won't have to do other kinds of
work later on you won't be forced to do
it choose to do it so that you won't be
compelled later on because by not
toiling toiling is not avoided right you
can avoid it right now you can take it
easy right now but it's going to bite
you in the butt as we say and you're
going to have to do more later on you're
even pursuing it whether you realize it
or not you are chasing after further
labor further ponos on your own part and
I think that there's another letter that
doesn't mention toil as such but is
really germane to this issue and I think
drives it home and this is letter 35 to
oper saying uh do well and do well not
in the sense of like be well but do
choose and do the right things so he
says that
um
I've concluded from my own case
that we human beings are distressed
precisely when we wish to live a life
without hardship
that is what a lot of people do in fact
desire a life without you might say
conflict right
um
and so a life in which we're not going
to have to continually work at things
this is an unrealistic way of thinking
about how our life could could look and
so he goes on and he says this wish is
impossible
right we must live with the body so
that's one source of kneading tutorial
and we must live with other people as
well and most hardships as he says uh
are going to arise or issue from the
Folly of those who live in society and
in turn from the body so if a wise
person lives by these principles then
they're going to be free from Pain and
confusion they're going to be happy but
if they're ignorant of these they're
never going to cease from being
dependent on vain hopes and being
constrained by desires and so he says
it's up to you buddy do you want to live
the life of the masses who don't have
their heads on straight when it comes to
this and dream about for example winning
the lottery and being on Easy Street
never having to do anything again in
their lives
totally unrealistic point of view
or do you want to live a more realistic
existence where you recognize you're
gonna have to put up with some stuff and
you're gonna have to work
but it's going to be better for you
there's the possibility of genuine
happiness being in a a good condition so
you know toil figures into there
another way in which toil is very
important you could say in the ethics of
the cynics we find this in in letter 15.
he says shun not only the worst of evils
Injustice and self-indulgence but also
their causes what are their causes
pleasures
for you will concentrate on these alone
and on nothing else and pursue not only
the best of goods self-control and
perseverance and the words for those
here and crates
these are two sides of the same coin
being able to restrain yourself from
indulging in pleasures and also being
able to you know stand up to pains to
discomfort to things that you don't
necessarily want to do and what's really
important here toils are the cause the
the thing that produces literally
poetica of self-control and endurance
if you want self-control and endurance
you have to apply yourself you're not
just going to be born with it it's not a
temperament thing you actually have to
work by doing things that you originally
don't really want to do and he says
don't shun toils on account of their
harshness right
in this this case and he says you know
you would you exchange inferior things
for something great just as you receive
gold in exchange for copper you would
receive virtue in exchange for toils
right so by doing toils you develop
virtue the thing that makes us really
good people and opens up the road to
happiness for us
there's a couple interesting examples
that are provided in these letters as
well so the first one that we'll look at
is in letter 20.
he is talking uh to metricles who is
hipparchia's brother and a student of
his and he says after you left us for
home I went down to the palestra of the
young men and after anointing myself
with oil so that's one of the things
think about going to the gym right
anointing yourself with oil okay we
don't typically do that but that was
something that they they did back in
ancient Greece quite a bit and a lot of
people just like sit around sort of like
a lot of people will go to the gym and
they'll do some exercises but it's just
all kind of light stuff they're not
going to go hit the weights they're not
going to get themselves into an
intensive class they're just you know
wandering around to look good and have a
social interaction maybe pick up a date
or something like that so he says when
the young men outside of me they started
laughing at me but I lest I cease too
quickly from exercising exhorted myself
so I'm talking to myself right I'm
giving myself you could say affirmations
and what did Karate say karates you are
toiling ponies right is is the the word
there for what for the eyes for the head
for the ears for the feet
you're toiling for these parts of your
body
you are taking care of them you're
running you're maybe doing some other
exercises these are going to keep you
and your bodily Parts in good condition
and what happens then
well these young men they hear him
saying this and they stop laughing
instead he says they made a start and
began to run and from that time on they
no longer merely anointed themselves
with oil but kept exercising and there's
a payoff to this what is that they are
not always sick as formerly they thanked
me for being the cause of their health
and did not leave me but continue to
follow me wherever I went listening to
me and imitating what I said and did and
he says you know I'm writing you
Metropolis so that you too might run not
by yourself but where the young men
spend their time we must provide for
them action teaches endurance more
quickly than words a tenant found only
in the philosophy of diogeny so he's
saying
show your toil to other people
show that you know and it's not just
working for the sake of working right
it's working out in an intentional way
so that you'll you'll feel better later
there are some letters addressed to
metropolis's sister hipparchia who
crantes married after she decided she
wanted to marry him and he said oh you
know cynic Lifestyles not for everyone
she's like you're the guy for me now
they lived apart at different points and
there's it's interesting because we get
a real contrast here so in in two of the
letters he's not actually using the word
um
toil and you know I'll actually mention
one other letter that's addressed to
hipparchia where he says women are not
by Nature worse than men women and men
can both do the same sorts of things
right but he goes on and he says
I'm returning this tunic that you wove
and sent to me why because those of us
who live a life of perseverance
right this uh endurance is another way
of translating it those of us who are
committed to the cynic lifestyle we
can't wear that kind of stuff and I do
so for another reason I want you to stop
doing this task which you've undertaken
with Zeal so that you might appear to
the masses to be somebody who loves her
husband so the typical work that would
indicate to the average person that
hyparkia really does love krates making
him garments making him clothing he's
like I don't want you to do that I want
you instead to be practicing philosophy
that's how you're going to be he says I
married you for the sake of philosophy
renounce these Pursuits and try to be of
Greater benefit to human life
um a little bit later in letter 32 he
says some have come from you bringing a
new tunic which they say you made so I
might have it for the winter because you
care for me I approved of you but
because you're still not practicing the
philosophy which I've tutored you I
censor you meaning I'm criticizing you
here and he says if you really care for
me stop doing this
stop doing this kind of work and instead
do the work on yourself that we
committed to as cynics in this kind of
marriage now in letter 33 he's praising
her instead so he's congratulating
hipparchia on the birth of presumably
their first child they had two children
according to uh you know what we know
about them he says I hear that you've
given birth and that quite easily thanks
be to God and to you
you believe it seems that toiling is the
cause of your not having to toil once
again we see what he had talked about in
letter four toiling at the start is a
reason for you not having to toil later
in this case it has to do with
childbirth and raising healthy children
a very important concern back then just
as it is now he goes on and he says
you would not have given birth so easily
unless while pregnant you'd continue to
toil as the athletes do doing physical
exercise right most women however when
they're pregnant are unfeeebled and when
they give birth those who happen to
survive bring forth sickly babies you
have a healthy baby because you actually
did physical work while you were
pregnant and so that made the labor
easier and now the baby is ready to be
initiated into a life of toil yourself
he says you'll take care of him if you
enter into child rearing with your usual
concern let his bath water be cold his
clothes be a cloak his food be milk not
to excess Rock him in a cradle made from
a tortoise shell this they say protects
against childhood diseases and then he
says when he's able to speak and walk
dress him not with a sword but a staff
and cloak and wallet and send them to
Athens what is a staph in Cloak and
wallet the typical
accoutrement of the cynic
Sage or a wise person or at least
somebody committed to cynicism we could
say the cynic practitioner so he's you
know congratulating her on having
applied this lesson about toil in a way
that benefits not just her but also
their child and presumably other people
as well so very interesting discussion
of the necessity of toil but it's not
just a acceptance and saying oh well we
all have to struggle it's choosing the
right kind of toil that is distinctive
of the cynic way of life